duras está a las puertas de una
transición política pero en un país
marcado por la corrupción el
narcotráfico y una pobreza que ronda el
70 por ciento la desconfianza en la
clase política es elevada pero siempre
se espera verdad que sea enjuiciado y
que no queden impunidad que todos estos
robos saqueos este actos de corrupción
sean castigados verdad como un
precedente para nuevas generaciones y
que puedan observar a nivel
internacional también que los hondureños
estamos haciendo las cosas
transparentemente honduras presenció el
primer golpe de estado del siglo 21 en
la región en 2009 militares sublevados
expulsaron del país al entonces
presidente manuel zelaya por su cercanía
ideológica con los gobiernos de
izquierda latinoamericanos
he sido secuestrado secuestrado a la
fuerza con violencia con brutalidad ese
secuestro es
son paso en país de una bofetada al
mundo entero desde entonces la
democracia en el país ha estado en
entredicho con altos índices de
corrupción desde la llegada de juan
orlando hernández a la presidencia en
2014 se ha acusado al ejecutivo de lazos
con el narcotráfico
concretamente de politizar los órganos
de justicia y control reducir el alcance
de las investigaciones y aprobar leyes
para blanquear la corrupción algo que
hernández siempre ha negado
brillaba con tiene muy mala
todo en 2015 una corte de nueva york
inició varios procesos políticos contra
figuras públicas y militares entre ellos
el hermano del ex presidente juan
antonio hernández finalmente condenado
una crisis política a la que se le sumó
la migratoria con caravanas promovidas
por la violación de los derechos humanos
y la falta de oportunidades en la nación
que enfrenta muchos retos
socioeconómicos un galopante descontento
social y altas cifras de violencia